regardez tiens regardez cette vidéo
regardez voilà elle sera l'anniversaire
de Raymon ce
soir
mais ça passe que va faire que va faire
que va faire cette jeune dame de 104 ans
un combat de MMA elle va rejoindre ses
amis dans le public de
slam elle va faire un son en parachute
ou elle va faire un marathon qu'est-ce
qu'elle va faire ti la BA la BA la BA
quoi un combat non rejoindre tes amis
dans le public de ca mais non un son
parachute un son en parachute Regardez
elle va faire un son qui qui a déjà fait
un son parachute ici Benaï ah oui toi
c'était moi c'est moi qui t' envoyé
Jean-Marie oui oui Jean-Michel ouais
tout j'ai fait l'armée donc ouis ça ça
ve rien dire Delphine jamais jamais ou
çaiis sûr que vous devz avez envie d'en
faireorit mon anniversaire demain mais
j'ai pas encore eu l'occasion tu sa que
c'est l'anniversaire de Raymond demain
mon anniversaire demain on
faire un tandem bah oui c'est vrai non
mais tu le fais tu fais un baptême avec
un mec tu es accroché après un mec ah
oui c'est vrai tu es déjème la C
accroché à cron sera pas un son
parachute juste tu vois la chute la
[Musique]
chutee
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je l'ai fait et ça fait un lifting
gratuitoup me j'ai d'abord donc au mec
et le gars pendant le vol mais dit tu
bouges bien les bras comme ça tu tu
retires pas un bras sinon on se retourne
donc tu es bien comme ça et il me fait
ça va et moi je fais ça va avec un grand
fil de B c'est qui part sur les lunette
du mec tu vois d'ailleurs arrivé dit toi
tu es moniteur de parachute dit oui bah
j'ai reconnu c'est au bas à la B sur sur
tes lunettes vous êtes que deux en ENF
ouais c'est formidable moi moi je vous
ai maudit le jour où vous m'avez envoyé
après je vous a embrassé parce que c'est
un c'est un truc un shoot d'adrénaline
absolument dingue c'est incroyable j'ai
adoré vous avez déjà fait la chute moi
j'ai fait une chute libre un jour de de
plusieurs mètres pour une émission pour
le début d'une émission émission je
faisais des cascades au début en début
d'émission Rapp c'est c'était génial
franchement j'avais kiffé et voilà je
voulais vous le dire ça me fait penser à
un truc ça me fait penser à un truc il y
a un monsieur qui a des avions des
avions de
chasserome anniversaire il vous a vouit
pas venir voulait pas qu'on le fasse on
le fait pas il vous a invité à faire des
des tours en avion de chasse faire des
des tours et tout il invité C ou tout le
monde non il a dit vous venez si vous
voulez venir on a invité à faire des il
a dit qui vous venez il a dit il a dit
cy il m'a laissé sa carte et tout et si
on veut y aller il nous fait des tour
écoutez écoutez ce son très mal
reproduit d'un toulousain et dites-nous
de qu il s'agit Alley oh put c'est
énorme on embrasse bien sûr tous les
Toulousains pourquoi a-t-il dit ça parce
qu'il est tombé sur un python dans ses
toilettes parce qu'il a trouvé une
pépite d'or d'un kg dans un champ parce
qu'il a aperçu gen Michel mer tout nu
ou parce qu'il a découvert mon nouveau
classement au padol ah il y a un piège
la c la C ou la D il y a un piège oui un
piton pris l'accent elle a pris
l'accent ah mais c'est génial pit mais
tu fais hyper bien ben je suis
toulousaine ah oui mais c'est vrai oui m
pit exactement
regardez imaginez vous allez
tranquillement au toilettes au beau
milieu de la nuit quand soudain vous
tombez sur
ça lundi dernier à 3h du matin un
Toulousain a eu la surprise de découvrir
un python d' 1,50 dans ces VC surpris
l'homme a immédiatement appelé les
pompiers qui ont capturé l'animal sain
et sauf avant de le placer dans une que
vétérinaire si cette espèce n'est pas
venimeuse sa morsure peut-être très
douloureuse selon les secouristes le
python aurait échappé à la vigilance de
ses propriétaire et seritentrer chez ce
Toulousain par une fenêtre laissée
ouverte là il est passé par la fenêtre
et à mot il était passé par les
canalisation autreire et en fait c'est
les nouveaux animaux de compagnie c'est
des cou fa bouffer le cul faut faire
gaffe
c'est sympa aussi ça pourrait pas vous
arver chez vous he C he par que serpent
n'accroche pas sur les chiottes en OR
ça allez on les achète dans des refuges
par exemple ça coûte 80 € un python ch
bébé bébé bébé mais alors mais après il
grandit connardè ça grandit non mais le
prix c'est pour le prix je dis ça grandè
c'est bébé et sil fut plus de 3 m il
faut avoir un certificat sinon on a pas
le droit sin c'est prison ah oui 3 M tit
on peut acheter un petit oui mais c'est
grandit grandit mais pas des gestes
comme ça chaîne tout le
monde Delphine du coup du coup c'est
quoi votre votre classement au paddle
parce que c'était dans
lesuse oh c'est grve ça c'est très
gra
[Applaudissements]
oh plus envie de baiser
hein
[Applaudissements]
non non non non
non elle a oui c'est bon elle a oui
c'eston oui
oui il y a rien qui va alors merci
Delphine vous êtes la seule qui vous
intéressz à moi ici voilà euh mon
nouveau classement de padle je vous le
dis je suis maintenant depuis mardi 110e
joueur français mais
non rien per per male 110 110 genre
40000 joueurs et j'avais dit objectif
top 100 rest 10 places et bien sûr si
j'y arrive vous serz tous invités gros
soir on fait quoi gr soirée vraiment
grosse soirée
il il faut impérativement que tu
affrontes des gens qui sont au-dessus de
toi pour grimper dans le truc ouais mais
ouais mais là je fais là je sa ce que je
fais hein tu sais je voilà faut que tu
tapes un 60e ou un 80 ah oui c'est ça
pourquoi vous l'avez pas dit
d'humilité l'humilité
extrêmement ité et merci merci merci ça
se fait pourquoi vousz
mercioir posé la question ah oui merci
parce que sinon c'est une information
qui serait restée cachée
exact les chéis on va parler de
l'araignée banane décidément ah oui
décidément ça ça m'intéresse je pense
que ça va vous plaire et merde parce que
j'ai donné directement la réponse
oui
bravo
l'araignée banane c'est l'une des
araignées les plus dangereuses au monde
elle pourrait être le remède miracle
contre les problèmes d'érection chez les
hommes ouais ah je en prendre deux
j regardez c'est pas une vane c'est dans
le JT regardez je raconte pas de
conneries l'araignée banane qui vit en
Amérique du Sud est l'une des espèces
les plus venimeus au monde et quand elle
mort ses victimes subissent toutes le
même symptôme le professeur Carlos rise
a constaté que les patients qui venaient
à la clinique après avoir été mordus par
cette araignée présentaient tous un
symptôme caractéristique le priapisme
qui est une érection douloureuse et
prolongée à partir du venin récolté ces
scientifiques ont créé une molécule de
synthèse qui reproduit les effets
érectiles breveté elle pourrait être
commercialisé
prochainement oui oui oui oui vous qui
vous connaissez un problème de oui vous
êtes le
spécialiste alors c'est une une araignée
don la piqû est mortelle c'est un velin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
neurotoxique en fait c'est ça quoi le
bail TDE pas ton mer de pas avec
l'araignée je vais rester comme ça ton
mer de pas c'est très bien passé pendant
toute cette année ton mer de pas avec
l'araignée ton mer de pas arrête arrête
avec cette araignée Pedro arrête le
tarif Pedro tu arrêtes avec cette
araignée ça va ça va très bien écoute on
à c'est bon oui et donc il a caresse
légèrement ah bah voilà comme ça
l'araignée l'araignée l'araignée
l'araignée il caresse l'araignée
légèrement elle sort deux trois gouttes
de venin il a transforme au Brésil et
ils en font un gel voilà dont ils
espèrent qu'il pourra palier les
problèmes d'érection alors ils ont fait
plein de séries de Test ils reste en PH
deest je pense que le test ultime c'est
vous
hein il faut vraiment prendre qu'un tout
petit peu parce qu'effectivement sinon
sinon c'est à la
FO non mais mais ça va
pas sinon c'est carrément
c'est sinon c'est douloureux et c'est
nécrose du pénis ah ouais ouais donc là
c'est Mo après il y a plus de substance
qui marche déjà il y a quoi donc tuas le
pénis d'abord qui est dur et
après non plus très c'est
c'est importantou non il y a plein de de
substances qui marchent le clou de girof
le gingambre le flambi les flambis flamb
flamb le sapran C les flambies ça marche
hy bien bien sûr les trucs là les faut
les GO les flambis bah vous tuz des
gobes et ça descend directement dans les
testicul le caramel ça a été
scientifiquement prouvé ça
scientifiquement prouvé le flamb c'est
ce qu'on m'a dit moi d'accord sû
toujours à la maison ça des
danettes oh non ah parce
tout le monde solè merci [__] on est
con une bonne
émission fait une bonne émission allez
question qu'est-ce qui a été vendu pour
4,2 million d'euros aux enchères un faux
tableau de Picasso un tableau de
Picassa un
masque un masque africain un chat le
chat qui était dans la gorge de Michel
marie
ou la bague que j'ai offert àvec Jil
Fatou en
2017 le B alors la bague que j'ai
offerte ouais et non pas la bague que
j'ai offert fait pourquoi parce que vous
avvez le queue qui est passé qui est
placé
avant toujours c'est pas possible rien
faireas rien à faire il y a rien à faire
ça alors la
question la réponse plutôt un masque
africain exactement g tu peux nous en
parler alors c'est un masque africain
qui est très rare parce que c'est une
société secrète qui fabriquait ses
masques au 19e il y en a que quelques
modèles dans le monde et un Antier un
brocanteur l'a acheté un couple ce
couple pensait lui vendre un vieux mas
qu'ils avaient trouvé en liquidant leur
résidence secondaire et puis le
brocanteter astucio l'a revendu 4
millions d'euros il l' acheté 150 €
sur50 € donc du coup le couple attaque
et estime que le brocanteur savait ouais
et ne leur a pas donné assez d'éléments
pour que se rendent compte qu'ils
avaient un objet de valeur donc ça va en
justice et il faut savoir que l'argent
la vente a été bloqué par un avocat pour
le moment le brocanteur n'aura pas ces 4
milli j'ai
décroché je sais pas si intéressé
quelqu'un cette histoire mais moi j'ai
décroché depuis bien longtemps
l'araignée c'était beaucoup mieux j'
encore sur l'araignée moi merci GG tu
l'as vu tout de suite hein ouais j'ai vu
ouais euh qui veut de l'arier
banane personne